if you think they're not going to come
for you oh my word do you have another
thing coming and I hope that you don't I
genuinely hope that you don't I I've had
people say that I was a hate speaker
because I said soccer was gay I do I
think so you think soccer's
gay homosexual
yes you know what that's a whole another
debate and if it is by the way I would
be happy to embrace its homosexual side
U well I know you would I think it's
great if you're a six-year-old girl or a
homosexual from Greece to quote Nick
depalo yeah you know the difference
between our football and your football
we don't wear helmets to protect
ourselves we we're real men over here
you also don't allow contact we're real
men over here it's uh it's there's no
great padding or you know great shoulder
pads and helmets we just get stuck into
each other that's a difference Americans
can Awards you like to wear helmets and
carry guns we just use these
guns but that's a whole that's the whole
other debate as well